-Our next guest is
a United States senator
from Montana.
Please welcome to the show
Senator Jon Tester.
Thank you for joining us,
Senator.
-Good to be with you, Seth
Thank you.
-So, you are both a senato
from Montana
and the only senator
who is a working farmer.
Which of those jobs --
be honest with us -- is harder
-Oh, wow.
I mean, for me,
I think it's being a senator
I mean, the truth is
there's a lot of things
you can't control
in production agriculture,
but there's a lot
of things you can't control,
being a United States
senator, too,
so I would I would say
there's a bigger challenge
Plus, there's so many things
worldwide and domestically
you have to deal with.
Yeah, it's being a U.S. senator.
-With that said,
you cannot be a farmer via Zoo
and I think that speaks to -
It's maybe a little bit
physically harder. [ Laughs
-Well, you know, yeah, it is
Physically,
it is much more difficult
because you're out working
And, by the way, the combination
of these two jobs
tends to make your body hurt
at night when you go to bed.
But it's good.
No, they're 180°° differen
in every aspect.
-Is it true that you butcher
and bring your own meat
from Montana to D.C.?
-It is, yes.
My wife and I ran
a custom butcher shop
from the time we took over the
farm, in the late '70s,
'til I got in the state
legislature, in the late '90s,
and so we tend to like to ea
the meat that we process
and that's what we do.
And then, I've got a beer cooler
that holds, you know,
a fair amount of beef
and, every month or so,
I'll bring out some meat to eat.
-So, we're about 100 days
into the Biden presidency.
You're obviously a Democrati
senator in a red state.
How is the -- or I should say,
how are the progressive policies
of Joe Biden
playing back home, so far?
-Well, look, I think Joe's
done a great job,
especially when it comes
to the pandemic,
and I think he's put forth
some policies
that'll help middle America,
regular folks.
You know, the jury is still out,
but, so far, so good.
I like what he's done, so far.
And I will tell you
that there are folks
that are always going to pok
holes for political reasons.
But, I think,
if you look at what Joe's done
in the last 100 days,
it's hard to be critical.
I think he's done a good job
-You talked, in your book,
about how, you know,
rural America and Democratic
you know, legislation
do tend to line up,
but maybe Democrats
don't do a particularly
good job with messaging
and it seems like rural Americ
has maybe just been ceded
to the Republican Party.
What do you think Democrat
have to do
to reconnect with rural Americ
and is something
like President Biden
proposing rural broadband
a step in the right direction?
-Yeah, broadband
is absolutely one
of the things that we need
to really focus on
because rural America
is very, very disconnected
There are a lot of people
that are unserved,
a lot of people underserved.
I got a cellphone that,
you know,
it works once in a while
when I'm on the farm,
but not very often.
But, overall,
I think Democrats need to talk
about what they're
accomplishing a lot more
and I think we need to go
into rural America
and put that message out.
And, I think,
if we were able to do that
I think we'd be
a lot more successful.
And infrastructure,
a good place to start, Seth.
And broadband's a good place
to start
in the infrastructure realm.
-You were one of the eight
Democratic senators to vot
against the federal minimum wage
increase to $15.
Yet, you've also advocated
for increasing
the minimum wage in the past
In 2014, you thought
it you go up to $10.
Why did you vote against i
and what do you --
obviously,
as someone who feels like
it should be higher
than what it is now,
what are the next steps forward?
-Well, I voted I voted
against the $15
because it was pretty unclear.
A lot of things in not
were not made clear,
like do benefits count,
for example.
And I think we ought
to encourage employers
to give benefits
for their employees.
But, that aside,
I will say this --
working people need to get pai
for their hard work.
There's no doubt about that.
What the right amount is,
is much more difficult,
as you've already said.
Here's why.
In rural America,
you know, Manhattan, Montana
is a lot different
than Manhattan, New York,
for example,
and those small businesses
mom-and-pop shops,
for the most part,
if they're closed down
because of this minimum wage
that's another nail
in the coffin of rural America
And we've seen rural America
dry up
the last 60, 70 years,
in a big, big way.
So I think we need
to be thoughtful about it.
There's a group,
there's a bipartisan group
that's coming together that,
hopefully, will come forth
with a proposal that will get us
to $15 over time
and I think that
will be something
that, hopefully, we can ge
bipartisan support for.
-I feel as though
we don't talk about,
on a national stage,
Native voters much.
They are a constituency
that has supported you
in your time in elected office
Obviously,
this is not a voting bloc
that's a monolith,
in any way, shape, or form
but how is it that you connect
with, you know, a voting group
that we, you know, simply just
don't talk about that much
-Well, it's a pretty
well-known fact
that Native Americans
have a lot of challenges,
especially the large
land-based ones.
And I will tell you that, no
unlike any other voting group,
if you go out there
and listen to their concerns
and really hear them
and come back and go to work
and try to solve some
of their problems,
letting them drive the bus
but letting the federal
government help them solve -
whether it's unemployment issues
or clean water,
I mean, issues that, by the way,
affect every community
in this country --
then, they'll support you.
If they know you're out there,
doing your best to take care
of the problems that they have
they will support you and
think that's pretty well proven.
It is a pretty decent
voting bloc in Montana.
It's about 6%, 7%,
of the population,
so it's significant.
But, more important
than that is that,
if you're able to lift up some
of the unemployment problems
that they have
in Indian country,
it literally helps
the entire state
and helps the entire country
-I want to finish
by asking you this.
My father-in-law,
who's a wonderful man
and a musician who lost a couple
of fingers, still plays guitar
Now, you lost one more finge
than he did.
You lost three fingers
in a farming accident, correct
-Yeah, I stuck my hand in th
meat grinder at the wrong time
and you never want to get
in a fight with power equipmen
because power equipment wins
-And, yet, you still say
being a senator is harder.
[ Laughter ]
Now, I think --
I think that's the worst thing
you said about D.C.
in this whole interview.
But, the thing I wanted
to get to --
because this is
a story of triumph --
you still learned how
to play trumpet, despite that.
How is that even possible?
-Well, this accident happene
in between my fourth
and fifth grade year.
In Big Sandy, Montana, the
started music in fifth grade
I was going to play saxophone,
to be honest.
Well, you're missing
three digits.
You aren't going to play sax
so, I took up trumpet
and it worked, man.
It just worked.
And, like I told my kids
and like my parents told me,
you got to be good at somethin
and I was a pretty decent
trumpet player,
at one time in my life,
and it propelled me
through college.
And, quite honestly,
when I started running
for the state legislature,
I brought my horn with me
and played a few tunes
when it was appropriate
and it helped me
in electoral politics, too
so it's been good.
I don't think
I'd be a U.S. senator
without my music, that's bee
in my past, for sure.
-Well, that is truly
a story of perseverance.
Thanks for sharing it
and thanks so much
for making time for us today
-Hey, Seth,
always a pleasure.
Thank you very much.